il est près de deux heures du matin de
faire traiter les tablettes s'il vous
plaît quand les esprits s'échauffent à
l'assemblée
tous les applaudissements de la majorité
présidentielle et les contestations de
l'opposition les députés reviennent sur
l'augmentation de 500 millions d'euros
des pensions de retraite comme il en a
le droit bruno le maire demande d'une
seconde délibération sur cet amendement
adopté en fin d'après midi contre l'avis
du gouvernement
revenez pas à ces méthodes du passage en
force ne serait ce que pour une chose
c'est que ça vous tiendrez pas sur cinq
ans sur le passage en force notre
position elle est d'intérêt général
puisque c'est le parlement qui a voté et
quand le parlement qui a voté c'est
l'intérieur et général qui s'est
exprimée la seconde délibération c'est
le match retour du mauvais perdant vous
êtes à l'instant des mauvais perdants et
vous ne pratiquez pas le jeu
démocratique
bientôt nous apprendrons la nature du
deal qui a été fait probablement ce soir
de cette méthode indigne dont vous serez
balayer plus encore
celle outre hc l'outrance c'est que
cisco gauche et aux partis extrémistes
entre mais c'est ce qu'on voit
l'assemblée c'est des mots de plus en
plus violents outrageux insultant et la
séance basque oui c'est non c'est pas la
peine de dire et hausse non je suis
désolé on ne s'adresse pas à la
présidence de cette façon là laissant la
vice-présidente de l'assemblée jouer les
maîtresses d'école seul monsieur le
ministre à la parole et les retraités de
france savent qu'aujourd'hui en public
et sur leurs enfants et leurs petits
enfants ils sont plus responsables que
vous ilan ubs qui se comporte comme un
communes comme un cirque comme un show
qui fait n'importe quoi qui fait du
chironomes d'aidé qui fait des
amendements à 3 heures du matin pour
renommer le texte sur le pouvoir d'achat
des miettes et du charbon ça démontre
aussi des deals probablement plus le peu
glorieux entre une majorité et certains
groupes qui on peut le dire de façon un
peu triviale retournent leur veste au
beau milieu de la nuit a pris peur suite
au vote de cet amendement est de voir
m'a dit mais ces de coursan
qu'est ce que vous voulez tuer je veux
un engagement du gouvernement sur la
réévaluation 1er janvier 2023 et denis
d'accord et puis nous avons fait des
compromis quand on nous est dit par
exemple ma votre dispositif sur
l'essence il faut qu'il puisse concerner
les retraités il faut qui touche tous
les français eh bien nous avons accepté
cette philosophie qui était proposée par
les républicains l'amendement qui était
portée par monsieur de courson avait pas
vocation à être votée en réalité il
avait dit lui même c'est un amendement
dakhla croyez pas bah ils n'y croyaient
pas pourquoi parce qu'ils étaient mal
fichu cet amendement c'est plus vous qui
faites la loi c'est on l'a jamais fait
si l'on était les défis c'est monsieur
s'il s'amuse à ces questions
drôle de rencontre pour une baignade ce
matin à hyères dans le var les pompiers
du département si elle est la présence
d'un requin bleu de deux mètres tout
près des plages de l'almanarre vous avez
criminaliser le fait de ne pas vouloir
garder des délinquants étrangers sur
notre sol vous avez culpabiliser les
gens vivent dans des années vous vous
avait régné sur ce pays pendant 40 ans
et ben c'est terminé les motards
franciliens soulagé le décret a été
abrogée ils n'auront pas à réaliser de
contrôle technique pour leur deux roues
non par monsieur le jeune soit un peu
comment dire critiques à mon égard
scanner fois qu on s'est croisés sans un
tribunal où il a été condamné donc
j'entends bien avoue-t-il
the
social
en espagne un adolescent a été sauvé de
la noyade par un drone la machine sans
pilote a laissé tomber un gilet de
sauvetage aux jeunes de 14 ans les
sauveteurs sont ensuite arrivés à l'aide
d'une embarcation le choc avec l'oni
témoigner au tribunal contre moi vous
étiez mis en examen pour injures et
terminer sa vie en exerçant tous mais
terminé mais c'est pour vous dire que
les terminales cirque maintenant vous
avez été condamné à maintes assure
qu'une condamnation pour injures à n'en
pas si vous vous êtes un circuit aménagé
par